an Apache crew putting their machine
through its paces in Afghanistan soon
it'll be Prince Harry at the controls of
one of these attack helicopters as his
second tour of Helmand gets underway
four and a half years after the media
blew his cover and ended his first stint
fighting the Taliban angry for the wrong
wrong word to use but no I'm sorry
disappointed I thought I could sit
through to the end come back with them
of our guys and then the colonel himself
in 2008 Harry was a forward air
controller calling in airstrikes in
support of coalition forces radio
conversation he'll be the air strike
there is sure to be more questions asked
about the wisdom of sending a Royal
Prince back to war where he'll present
the ultimate prize to the enemy should
anything go wrong though the former head
of the Army General Sir Mike Jackson
says Harry signed up to fight and fight
he must let's be clear both of these
young princes chose to join the Armed
Forces and I applaud them for that
decision they both know what's involved
it comes with the job and they both will
these two young men I've no doubt
understand that fully this is the other
side of the party Prince just a couple
of weeks ago frolicking in the buff in
Las Vegas now preparing to kill in
southern Afghanistan but why is the
fun-loving Harry putting his life on the
line again former Royal Marine Ben
mcbean who lost an arm and a leg in
Helmand serving in the same brigade as
Prince Harry in 2008 and who the Prince
called a hero thinks he knows the answer
as a Marine as a soldier in general you
want to go to war you know you don't
just want to say I spent 22 years in the
forces
where'd you go know you know you want to
go to war and say that you want to get
your medals out and say I've been there
I've done that and he's exactly the same
which is why you know even though he's a
royal when you went through training he
would work through exactly the same as
everyone else
so mentally and physically
he's come on the same way everyone else
imagine Apache pilot again he's gonna
want to go out there this is the lasting
image of Prince Harry's first truncated
tour to Afghanistan four years ago now
he'll be in control of even more
firepower and coalition forces on the
ground we'll know he can deliver a
strike his Taliban cannot counter Debbie
Bowden Sky News